revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 me acompañan en el estudio de
rosa pérez más de rosa bienvenida ya
estamos a cuadros casi finalizando la
semana y vamos a abrir entonces la
revista de prensa del día de hoy en
brasil como titula la confesión del
pescador que dice haber matado al
periodista británico con philips y el
ambientalista brasileño bruno pereyra
buenos días raúl exactamente la prensa
de brasil pues ballena en sus portadas
pues de esta información y desee pues
adelante o un poco de la investigación
que dado el resultado pues que gran
parte del mundo pues temían hoy es pues
finalmente el hallazgo de los cuerpos de
esta pareja que como bien decíamos en
los noticieros pues investigaba
precisamente las actividades de
explotación de los recursos de forma
ilegal en esta zona de la amazonía de
brasil la fue la de sao paulo dice
pescador asume las muertes en la
amazonía dice la policía federal y la
policía federal como bien decías explicó
que uno de los hermanos digamos acusados
y autores confesos al menos pues de
estos asesinatos o su implicación
asesinatos pues llevó a las autoridades
hasta el lugar donde habían enterrado
los cuerpos por otro lado vemos también
ya portadas muy gráficas no es muy
impactantes como la de estado de minas
que dice verde manchado de sangre y es
que bueno como comentábamos en otras
ocasiones en el área del amazonas donde
desapareció la pareja el periodista
británico y el ambientalista el defensor
de la amazonía bruno pereyra pues es una
zona que está muy concurrida por grupos
ilegales de pesca ilegal de caza ilegal
y que atacan y se confrontan
habitualmente con la población indígena
de hecho hay que recordar que la pareja
investigaba precisamente estas
actividades que había sido amenazada
antes de su desaparición y que según la
organización global witness brasil es el
cuarto país más peligroso para los
defensores ambientales después de
colombia méxico y filipinas y
precisamente en relación a la violencia
que comportan estas explotaciones
soy legítimas de los recursos naturales
en la amazonía el correio braziliense
titula las venas abiertas de una
barbarie en relación a las venas
abiertas de américa latina' esta obra de
eduardo galeano
así es rosa y es que a medida que pasan
las horas se van conociendo detalles
como también lo veíamos en el informe
que presuntamente también una tercera
persona habría participado que habría
sido supuestamente como lo dice uno de
los arrestados el asesino y que yo
solamente pues incinerar los cuerpos
rosa pero como como lo titula también o
como lo señala mejor dicho globo y carta
capital pues o globo da muchos detalles
de esta investigación los que se conocen
al menos hasta el momento como que
habría estado implicado a un arma de
fuego aunque todavía no se han realizado
las autopsias pero plantea no cuestiones
que siguen abiertas como sobre todo
quien dio la orden quien planeó el
asesinato por qué y recuerda y cita una
carta con la que se amenazó a la
ambientalista brasileño de la pareja
bruno pereyra una carta que dice sé que
están mandando a los indios a la zona
nuestras máquinas y tomar nuestro
pescado les advierto esta vez si sigue
así será peor para ti prepárate estás
advertido y es que dos meses antes hace
dos meses pereira ayudó a la policía al
mapear e identificar una organización de
pesca y caza ilegal y entre los miembros
de esta organización identificó a los
dos hermanos pues que ahora están
arrestados y que han confesado como bien
decías en su participación en incinerar
los cadáveres y también o'globo pues
define brevemente cuáles eran los
perfiles de los dos asesinados dice don
phillips apasionado por brasil el
periodista inglés asesinado en el
amazonas murió en el bosque que quería
salvar y bruno pereyra mayor indigenista
de su generación
bruno araujo pereira hablaba cuatro
idiomas javarí y veía a los indígenas
como hermanos por último carta capital
pues como decía saber igual
indica las averiguaciones de la policía
sobre la tercera persona implicada en
estos asesinatos y cita al delegado de
la policía federal que dice bruno
pereyra y don felipe no fueron los
primeros y no creo que sean los últimos
triste de rosa que estas personas mueran
por defender al final pues algo que nos
compete a todos y que todos y emocional
que es el planeta vamos ahora a cambiar
la información rosa el sur de europa a
través de una ola de calor que no es
usual para este mes de junio exactamente
raúl pues también una consecuencia
ambiental no todo está pues muy
vinculado en lo que se refiere a la
defensa del medio ambiente y vemos
precisamente en dos medios franceses por
un lado reportero que se dedica sobre
todo a la información ambiental y muy
crítico pues con la lucha contra el
cambio climático pone esta viñeta en la
que vemos la chica que se ató a la red
del roland garros este torneo de tenis
en francia digamos ha denunciado la
inacción contra el cambio climático y
hace el vínculo con el bac que es un
examen que pasan los franceses al
terminar el instituto en este examen de
filosofía y pregunta es justo defender
sus derechos por todos los medios la
chica responde si los guardas que la
arrestan responden evidentemente no y
por otro lado tenemos una viñeta de sus
siete también en largo de cine que pone
alerta acá ni culpa ni culpó es ola de
calor y vemos en manuel macro na
cruzando los dedos diciendo milán son
podría morir en esta ola de calor y
vemos a elisabeth von su primera
ministra diciendo nuestros electores
también no también el electorado de la
plataforma presidencial caracterizado
por ser más bien mayor y pues un poco de
cara a la guerra está sucia del macrismo
contra la unión de izquierdas de cara a
las legislativas que celebrarán su
próxima vuelta este domingo así es rosa
muchísimas gracias como siempre por la
revista de prensa nos vemos mañana con
más pasamos a saludar a nuestra primera
invitada al día